you really are a and I understood maybe
two of them but you are a huge movie
buff yeah yeah oh my god anything that's
out right now forget you know movies
from 10-15 years ago what's out right
now that's following your mind Mad Max
fury road chance to see it yet I have
not just see it I know I keep wanting to
go but like no you've got to come home
that's Annie that's Andy talking I might
look back me up
it's amazing yes everyone says that I I
love it and even though I got cut out of
it I love see it three times
wait a minute you got what you got cut
out of I got the Mad Max I ran out of it
yeah yeah it's well okay anyone has seen
the movie there are these amazing car
chases they're just that's what everyone
says yeah sure desert they're just enjoy
ganti and there's a guy the bad guy has
a dude with an electric guitar with a
flamethrower on it and he's like on the
top of a truck and as the bad guy [ __ ]
he plays left guitar like gets the NES
got other guys with drums and they play
music I brought a picture the guy there
he is
alright he's and he has a name he's
called the doof warrior the two for I
swear to God no I don't know how you do
that this movie well I also was I played
a character the bag I also had a
stand-up comedian on top of another
truck I kind of understand a guy with a
guitar and a flame thrower and then
there's a drummer on a truck yeah did
they they originally called for a stand
of anything that Rosie I was me and I
was you know just like you know throwing
out jokes like keeping the bad guys
going and he thought and I disagreed but
you know what George Miller is a genius
he just thought it's I brought the heat
I brought the clip installment you
brought that you probably let me bring
the
yeah what that was cut out of Mad Max
everyone doing today
I want to say we're to drop but last
night I ejaculated sans leg just got
back from gas town or as I call it del
Taco hey furiosa IV furiosa - Department
give me that haircut okay I'm on fire
literally I'm I'm on fire the bottom
half of my body out here can't believe
Ted Cruz only been president for two
weeks I started added but he just I
don't know I think he made the right
call I just don't think it calls for
senator media that's wow I'm sorry okay
I'm sorry
well I'll see you on the DVD extras my
friend hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography